l'invitation du premier ministre est
arrivé il ya quelques jours le 13
novembre
gaëtan comme d'autres victimes du
bataclan recevra une médaille de
reconnaissance un symbole important pour
sa reconstruction
cette médaille ça représente la
reconnaissance de l'état à la
reconnaissance de ce que j'ai vécu la
reconnaissance de la douleur que j'ai pu
j'ai pu vivre ça m'aide à pouvoir
remettre un peu de sens par rapport à
tout ça et puis à essayer de mieux vivre
avec quoi finalement
trois ans après le drame le père de
famille n'a rien oublié de cette soirée
du 13 novembre 2015
il reste encore aujourd'hui des images
et des sensations cet homme qui est mort
sur moi des fois je perçois son souffle
sur sur ma nuque et puis le sang qui
coule dans mon oreille ça oubliez je
crois que j'en ai ce n'est pas possible
en tout cas si moi j'oublie mon corps
lui n'oublie pas aujourd'hui gaëtan doit
apprendre à vivre avec ses souvenirs
mais certaines situations restent
difficiles à gérer
et quand même une peur assez assez
profond des mouvements de foule des
foules danse du vous dire quand on est
très proche d'autres j'en sais quelque
chose qui est assez insupportable
on essaie d'avoir une vue globale de
tous et puis d'être très très très
sensible à tout ce qui peut se passer
tous les bruits un peu à un peu qui
sortent de l'ordinaire
après l'attentât le jeune professeur
s'est rapidement remise au travail
il est aujourd'hui directeur d'école
mais avec une vision de la vie
différente l'appareil l'idée que tout
peut s'arrêter très rapidement et que
tout est très fragile et que malgré tous
les instants qu'on peut vivre avec ceux
qu'on aime et il faut en profiter
pleinement profiter pleinement de chaque
seconde pour se sentir vivant